I was sitting on the edge of the boat my
back against the water mask check fins
check air pressure 3000 psi I grabbed my
camera and started the countdown three
two one
I rolled back and hit the water as the
bubble settled and the visibility
cleared I felt it
this could be the dive I have always
dreamed of as I descended I was
surrounded by over 70 sharks from
different species we reached the sandy
floor and from the semicircle my mom was
to my left I started shooting away my
favorite a beautiful lemon shark arrived
finally twenty minutes into the dive the
thing I've been waiting for two massive
tiger sharks one of them measuring over
15 feet in length
they started circling the group and
getting close very close as the larger
of the two sharks swim past me heading
towards my mom I saw its eyes turn white
something they do right before biting
the shark suddenly turned and smacked me
with its tail I lost my balance but as
soon as I regained it I click the
shutter and saw the scariest image I've
ever taken the shark took a bite at my
mom luckily she have her camera with her
and was able to use it as a shield but
the shark kept biting pushing her
further and further away from the group
with each bite
finally it let go
just when I thought we were safe the
shark turned and this time headed
straight at me the same thing happened
it's I turned white and a bite followed
after this we decided to abort the dive
once we reach the surface and the fear
and adrenaline invaded my head flooded
with questions why did the dive go so
wrong who was at fault in hindsight we
changed the behavior of the shark by
chumming the water which is putting that
bait in a cage to lure them in the shark
was acting normal
it was looking for the food it was
sensing in fact it was even being gentle
remember this animals weigh 1,500 pounds
have teeth as sharp as razors that can
crush a turtle's shell just like that
yet none of us had a scratch not my mom
not me not even the crystal dome of the
camera had a scratch this dive was a
turning point for me for the past 10
years I've been traveling the most
remote places in the world looking for
animals that we've driven to the brink
of extinction all to promote
conservation through photography my
thinking was that if I show you the
giant of the ocean some of its tiniest
creatures there's a seahorse in there
let's see if you can spot it or even
pixels most famous stars
your mind will be flooded with curiosity
and you want to experience and explore
the ocean and I know deep inside that
once you do you'll fall in love with it
and want to protect it just like I did
however I was not having the impact I
hoped for as much as I wanted my passion
and love for the ocean to be contagious
the truth is we are very detached from
the ocean and it is very hard to protect
something that seems so foreign for
example on the Left we have a picture of
my Labradoodle smokey this handsome dog
got a hundred and seven likes on
Instagram on the right we have a flying
whale with only forty four likes I mean
smoke is very cute and all but two and a
half times as cute as a flying whale
moreover after my encounter with the
shark I finally understood that there's
no image beautiful enough or a story
compelling enough that I can tell you
that that I can tell someone who's
afraid of the ocean or afraid of sharks
that will make them want to dive I fear
I could now relate to if I couldn't
reach people's hearts I needed to find a
better way I came across this
organization called Oceana whose mission
is save the ocean feed the world I
realized that the ocean is much more
than a beautiful place today 1 billion
people depend on the ocean including
some of the world's poorest but we're
taking much more than the ocean can
produce and in the process with the
destroying a very delicate balance that
took millions of years to perfect to add
to the problem we will soon reach 9
billion people and we don't have the
resources to fill such a large and
growing population
the ocean offers an abundant and
sustainable source of food for the world
and on like land-based agriculture or
farming wild fish produce no greenhouse
gases does not consume our precious and
scarce freshwater and does not utilize
fertile land but to take advantage of
this natural resource we need to change
the nature of our relationship with the
ocean sharks are a sign of a healthy
ocean because they protect the coral
reefs by controlling the population of
smaller predatory fish who feed on
herbivores without these herbivores
algae expands and coral can no longer
compete killing of the reef these reefs
are critical they are the breeding
ground for all fish species without them
fish populations plate today we kill a
hundred million sharks per year that is
almost twelve thousand sharks per hour
imagine the impact we are having on the
balance of marine ecosystems we have
already wiped out over 90% of all large
fish species like tunas and sharks
in contrast sharks killed 12 humans per
year so I ask you who is the deadliest
predator who should we be afraid of for
some people
images like the ones I've shown you
awaken our sense of wonder and make us
want to explore what 70% of the world's
surface is made of for others not so
much but no matter what group you're in
the ocean is our most precious and
valuable resource and it holds a key to
our future so what can we do to protect
it we can follow and support
organizations like Oceana
we can elect government officials who
support corrosion policy and we can eat
sustainable food it is not too late we
can replenish fish populations in as
little as 10 years making this goal
attainable in our lifetime and easier to
push in the political
agenda let's change how we coexist with
the ocean and together let's provide 1
billion healthy and sustainable fish
meals a day to the world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]